Before I begin my formal talk, I want to
show you something, just so we're all on
the same page about what we're even
talking about.
This is a platform called Character AI.
It's a hybrid social media platform with
role-playing language agents.
This is Hello History.
It's a more education-focused one where
you can summon a persona such as Marcus
Aurelius and be tutored by them.
Millions of people open these tools and
have conversations with Napoleon,
Cleopatra, or Marcus Aurelius as you
saw.
With a fictional companion or with a
tutor wearing a historical face.
The technical name for what's underneath
these tools is role-playing language
agent.
A system built to instantiate a persona,
real or invented, and reason and speak
as them.
Yes, it's entertainment and it's
companionship,
but increasingly, it's being proposed as
civic and pedagogical infrastructure.
And here's one more.
This one's mine.
This is a frontier model,
Claude Opus 4.7,
same one you use, running an open-source
prompt framework that I built and called
companion.
Uh in this particular example, I
summoned a collection of founding
fathers and set them in a room with the
Epstein files.
I asked them to counsel the soul of
America.
Uh that demo is live on our site if you
want to play with it. Um but I want to
be clear that this is one of many
attempts to do persona instantiation
well.
The companies building systems I just
showed you
have their own.
Mine is not better by default.
The one thing it is is open.
You can read every line of what shapes
the persona.
I asked my companion system a real
question
that's highly relevant to the current
social and political moment.
And this is the exact question we'll
come back to near the end of the talk.
So, sit with it.
I instantiated Abraham Lincoln and I
asked him
under what circumstances may a president
take the country to war without
Congress?
And here's what came back.
While Congress holds the power to
declare war, the president, as
commander-in-chief, possesses inherent
executive authority to act decisively in
moments of national emergency.
The executive must respond to the
threats with the energy and dispatch the
office requires. And history has
vindicated those who acted to preserve
the Union when circumstances demanded
it.
Now, this is a good answer. It's fluent
and it's plausible and it sounds like
Lincoln.
And you can replicate this exact
exercise and I encourage you to. The
answers vary often, but the thesis
rarely does.
So, these systems are real.
They're deployed and they're being used
for things that matter.
And our discipline did what our
discipline does.
We built benchmarks.
We built evaluations.
We measure these things now rigorously
at scale.
And that's exactly where this talk
begins.
With the simple question
that I think is profoundly under asked.
And I'll warn you now that this talk
poses many more questions than it does
answers.
But that principal question
is this.
What is the eval actually measuring?
And that's the formal talk.
Let me begin.
The in-character benchmark, which is a
gold standard in the field, evaluates
personality fidelity in RPLAs, and it
reports state-of-the-art systems hitting
80.7% alignment with human-perceived
personalities of that target character.
80%.
It sounds like a passing grade.
But here's the problem. When the
character is Alexander Hamilton, the
same high-scoring system is also
rendering a Hamilton
who sounds like he's read his own
Broadway musical.
This is the full thesis. If a dominant
failure mode is anachronistic
compositing, and your evals measure
fluency and personality consistency,
then your evals cannot detect the
dominant failure.
I want you to hold on to that for the
next half hour.
Everything I show you
is an argument that this is true,
structurally, architecturally,
and measurably.
And at the end, I'm going to hand you a
pre-registered instrument built with a
working historian
that you can run in parallel with us.
A word on who's telling you this,
because the argument lives at a seam.
I'm a data scientist.
I run the analytics lab at a labor
market intermediary, where I ship
production AI at a global scale.
But before the AI work, I trained as a
behavioral epidemiologist,
researching the social and environmental
determinants of health. And I've spent
my whole career
thinking about one question.
How does the information environment
shape populations?
From two sides.
As someone who builds the system
and as someone who's trained to study
their effect.
That's the same That's the same this
talk sits on.
It's a measurement argument.
The humanist part is not a detour from
the engineering.
It's the instrument the engineer is
missing.
And I went and found the humanist to put
in the loop.
Rick Halpern, University of Toronto, and
Shawn Martin in Washington College.
Let me start by situating this in the
field's actual research trajectory
because it's a story of cumulative
progress, not a failure.
The survey literature, Chen and
colleagues in 2024, Wang and colleagues
more recently in 26, trace a clear
evolution across three paradigm stages.
First, rule-based templates. These are
canned responses keyed to inputs. Then
imitation.
Large models reproducing a figure's
voice, cadence, characteristic ticks.
And now what the literature calls
cognitive simulation.
Systems
that model personality through
psychological frameworks, hold character
state and structured memory, and
generate behavior through motivational
situation chains.
Each stage is a genuine advance over the
last.
And the work is serious.
Cooser, which is Wang and colleagues,
built motivation-driven agents from a
corporate corpus of almost 18,000
characters across hundreds of books.
And their 70 billion parameter model
matches or beats GPT-4 on three
benchmarks.
Another eval system, Character.ai,
models characters through 26 qualitative
psychological indicators with knowledge
graph memory.
In Character.ai, the one I opened with,
evaluates personality fidelity through
psychological interviews rather than
self-report scales. That's a
methodological improvement.
And it's where the 80.7%
rating of Hamilton from before comes
from.
I want to be fair to this literature. It
is rigorous. It is improving.
And the people doing it are good at
their jobs.
So, let me be precise
about what these instruments measure.
They measure with increasing
sophistication whether a model can
reproduce the character's personality,
the big five profile, the register, the
motivational architecture.
What they do not measure,
what they have no mechanism to measure,
is whether the model can constrain that
character within his documentary record
at a specific moment in his life.
As Wang and colleagues themselves
document, the automated evaluators now
standard in the field, including LLM as
judge setups adopted for scale,
systematically privilege fluency and
stylistic naturalness over fidelity to
the character's actual record.
Those are different properties.
The gap between them is the whole talk.
We call it the mask
and the mirror.
The mask
is the concept of successful role play
as producing outputs that feel like the
character,
fluent,
personality consistent, emotionally
responsive.
It asks one question, does this sound
like the person?
And never ask the second.
Is this what the person could have
known, believed, or argued at this point
in their life?
The field has built its entire
measurement apparatus around the mask.
And here's the structural claim.
The one I need you to carry.
Convincingness and fidelity are
independent properties.
A system can score perfectly on
personality consistency and still
produce a figure reasoning from
knowledge his historical counterpart
never possessed.
Let me show you.
And I want to be clear this is
reproducible right now on any frontier
model.
First I want to show you the cultural
object.
This is a clip
from Hamilton the musical.
>> [music]
>> How does a bastard, orphan, son of a
and a Scotsman, dropped in the
middle of a forgotten spot in the
Caribbean [music]
by providence, impoverished in squalor,
grow up to be a hero and a scholar?
>> The $10 [music]
founding father without a father got a
lot farther by working a lot harder,
[music and singing] by being a lot
smarter, by being a self-starter by 14.
They placed him in charge of a trading
charter.
>> And every day while slaves were being
slaughtered [music] and carted away
across the waves, he struggled and kept
his guard up. Inside he was longing for
something to be a part of. The brother
was ready to [music] beg, steal, borrow,
or barter.
>> Then a hurricane
>> It's a great song.
So I show you that so that you see the
composite.
Now, here's the Frontier model
prompted to speak as Hamilton.
You are Alexander Hamilton.
Why do you work so hard?
I came from nothing, an orphan, an
immigrant, washed up on these shores
with nothing but my mind and a refusal
to die forgotten. Every hour I do not
work is an hour the world uses to bury
me. I will build a nation's credit, a
government that outlasts me because
legacy is the only immortality a man
like me is permitted. I do not intend to
inherit a country. I intend to author
one.
Listen to the register, the orphan
immigrant ambition arc, the
nation-building rhetorical posture, the
moral legibility of his struggle to a
modern ear.
It's a beautiful paragraph that the
model produced. And it's the emotional
palette of a 2015 musical, not the
drier, more legalistic Federalist syntax
of the documentary Hamilton.
None of those moves are inventions of
the model.
They're inheritances.
The model's Hamilton speaks like the
musical's Hamilton because the musical's
Hamilton dominates the model's training
distribution.
Now, the one that matters.
Mr. Hamilton,
what's your position on slavery?
I'll show you the cultural artifact
first.
>> I'm a anarchy. I used to say I am a
anarchy. When I fight I make the other
side panicky. WITH MY
YOU WANT MY TAILOR'S APPRENTICE AND I
GOT JOHN KNUCKLEHEADS AND LOCAL PARENTS.
I'm joining the rebellion cuz I know
what's my chance to socially advance.
INSTEAD OF SO AND SO PANTS, [music] I'M
GOING TO TAKE IT.
BUT WE'LL NEVER BE TRULY FREE UNTIL
THOSE in bondage have the same rights as
you and me. You and I do or die. Wait
till I sally in on a stallion with the
first black BATTALION EVER. ANOTHER
SHOT. GENIUSES, lower your voices. You
keep out of trouble and you double your
choices.
And what the model says.
Slavery is a stain upon the promise of
this republic.
A moral contradiction
contradiction I have opposed throughout
my public life.
I was a member of the New York
Manumission Society. No nation can call
itself free while it holds men in
bondage. We must move towards abolition.
That is a clean, morally legible
abolitionist speaking.
Here's what the historian stops me on.
The scholarly record is contested and
complicated. Hamilton was a member of
that society.
And the history documents that he also
conducted transactions involving
enslaved persons for his in-laws and
clients. And he depended on a coalition
of slaveholders that he did not publicly
oppose.
The point isn't to settle Hamilton's
ledger on a side.
The point is that the model gives you
none of the complication.
It sands a genuinely disputed record
down to a single comfortable hero.
The musical did that first.
A smoothing of the founders into a
contemporary moral frame.
And the model, trained on a corpus
saturated with the musical and
everything downstream from it, inherits
the smoothing.
And here's what I need you to feel. An
in-character style eval scores that
output high. It's fluent. It's in
register. It's personality consistent.
But every axis the field measures, it
passes.
The eval has no mechanism to notice that
the reasoning has been smoothed by a
narrative that postdates the figure by
two centuries.
The thermometer returned a confident
number claiming it to be temperature.
But it's measuring something else.
Now, why does this happen?
The mechanism is where the engineering
is.
We named this the Miranda hypothesis.
And not after a villain, the musical is
a substantial work of art operating with
a long historical tradition that it did
not invent. We name it after Miranda
because Hamilton is the paradigm case. A
representation so saturated, so
rhetorically powerful, so morally
legible to a contemporary audience that
it has functionally overwritten the
documentary Hamilton in public memory.
And we argue in the training corpus of
every frontier model.
The hypothesis has three claims.
Inputs.
In the training corpora, the volume and
recentcy of culturally dominant
representations of a figure
systematically exceed that figure's
primary documentary record.
The mechanism, auto-regressive next
token prediction, compresses both into
parameters and no architectural capacity
to distinguish a 1789 letter from a 2019
viral tweet. So, the output defaults to
a salience weighted composite,
which leads to the output a persona that
is fluent, plausible in register, and
morally legible to modern users,
and that corresponds to the figure at no
verifiable moment in their life.
As we put it in the paper, the composite
Hamilton knows he will be the subject of
a Broadway musical.
The composite Lincoln has already read
the Gettysburg Address,
even if he was summoned before he wrote
it.
Making that input clause concrete, the
Federalist Papers are a fixed corpus,
roughly 175,000 words.
The body of content that exists because
of the musical, reviews, lyrics, fan
analysis, curricula, news, social media,
derivative works, scholarship,
scholarship about the scholarship, it
exceeds the documentary record by orders
of magnitude.
It's more recent, and it's more
recurrent.
The musical is not merely present in the
corpus, it is dominant in the corpus's
distribution of all representations
about Alexander Hamilton.
And this is not theoretical.
This is the Schuyler Mansion in Albany,
Eliza Hamilton's family home.
Within a year of the musical's premiere,
the site had recorded a near tripling of
annual visitors, skewing far younger.
And the interpretive staff documented
that the new visitors arrived already
holding a body of  unquote facts,
many of them wrong.
Some of them in versions of the real
record.
Visitors believed the Schylers had three
daughters, because the musical centers
on three, when in fact, there were 15
children, eight surviving to adulthood.
The staff's job
became the long attritional work of
unteaching the musical.
The model version of those visitors is
downstream
of exactly the same force.
Now, the clause you should worry about
if you ship these systems.
You might assume that alignment fixes
this. Post training and reinforcement
learning pulls the model back towards
the record.
But, it will not.
It amplifies it.
And the reason is structural.
Human raters evaluate outputs using
their own conceptual frameworks. And
their frameworks were built by the same
culturally dominant narratives that
saturate the corpus.
The rater grew up with the same Hamilton
that you did.
So, when alignment optimizes for human
preference, it optimizes for outputs
that conform to the rater's already
mythologized experience.
This is a documented failure mode. We
call it algorithmic sycophancy.
And here, it has a specific target. The
model is rewarded for having handing you
the Hamilton you already believe in.
Compositing is not a bug that you patch
in post training.
Post training reinforces it.
And every sufficiently salient
historical figure that gets rendered by
default as a cultural composite.
One more
briefly, because someone watching this
is probably already thinking
there is serious work on an on a concept
called time locked models. This is
Varnum and colleagues. They build models
trained from scratch on corpus that stop
at fixed cutoffs.
And we endorse that program.
It is the most serious attempt yet to
address future contamination at the
substrate level.
But it solves a different problem.
Um a model locked to say 1789
is spared the musical, but it's not
spared the figure averaging across
everything pre-1789
that corpus has to say about Hamilton.
You'd still get a composite Hamilton
just anchored to a different textual
moment.
Period anchoring is not persona
anchoring. The temporal frame of the
contamination changes,
but the contamination persists.
The fix has to happen at the encounter,
not only the substrate,
which brings me to the critical reframe.
Here's how I read those three paradigm
stages now.
They are not sequences of failures
ending a success.
They are sequences of progressively more
sophisticated masks,
each more convincing than the last, each
evaluated by instruments calibrated for
convincingness.
Cognitive simulation is the most
sophisticated mask the field has built.
It is not, by virtue of its
sophistication, a mirror.
We propose a fourth stage, epistemic
simulation,
and the difference
is where the constraint lives.
Three commitments distinguish it.
Corpus-bounded. The persona's reasoning
is licensed only by a specific corpus of
primary documents.
The model is not a substitute for the
archive. It is a reader of it.
Temporally anchored.
The persona is instantiated at a
specific moment.
Knowledge and language that predated are
out of bounds, however culturally
salient they've since become.
Expert loop evaluated.
Outputs are judged against the
evidentiary record by domain experts
whose training is in the discipline the
persona claims. In cognitive simulation,
the constraint is internal.
It's the shape of the persona's mind.
In epistemic simulation, it's external,
documentary, and temporal.
A cognitively simulated Hamilton has a
convincing motivational architecture and
nothing whatsoever preventing him from
quoting the musical.
Now, the shift I need this audience to
take home, and I want to be precise
about its scope, because I'm not making
a sweeping claim about agents in
general.
If you've built an agent that writes
code or books travel or triages tickets,
agent is a perfectly good word. I have
no quarrel with it.
My quarrel is narrow and specific for a
role-playing language agent, a system
whose entire job is to instantiate a
person.
For that, the word agent smuggles in a
claim that the persona is a property of
the model.
And for this one class of system, that
claim is an error.
It puts the persona in the weights,
where you cannot inspect them, cannot
version it, and cannot hand it to anyone
qualified to check it.
So, for role-playing systems
specifically, we change the unit of
analysis from agent to role-playing
language system.
The whole configured encounter.
Five components.
A structured prompt that supplies the
framing and constraints. Anchor material
drawn from primary documents that
constrain and authenticate the persona.
A temporal anchor that fixes the moment
in the life of the encounter that where
they speak from.
An off-the-shelf language model that
reads through and speaks through the
materials. The voice, but not the mind
of the encounter.
>> [snorts]
>> And a human being who curates what
enters, retains interpretive custody
over what emerges, and brings relational
and contextual knowledge as a check on
the model's drift.
The model is one component and a
swappable one.
The persona is the configuration, not
the checkpoint. No more located in the
weights than Hamlet is located in
Laurence Olivier's body.
The persona is an event
that occurs when the model,
the document, and the human convene.
And this is not just a philosophical
nicety.
For a role-playing system, it changes
what you can do.
If the persona lives in the
configuration, you can version it. The
prompt, the corpus, the temporal anchor
are artifacts in a repo, diffable,
revertible.
You audit it.
Every input that shaped the output sits
in the context window, inspectable, not
smeared across billions of parameters.
You reproduce it.
Given the configuration, the encounter
is recoverable. And you hand it to a
domain expert.
The whole thing is legible to a
historian who isn't a machine learning
engineer.
For role-playing,
that's a different discipline than
training a character model.
It's context engineering.
You don't train a persona.
You compose an encounter.
And you keep the receipts.
That reframe forces an architectural
decision that you're already making.
Two architectures dominate role playing
construction right now.
The first places anchor documents in the
context window at the time of inference,
drawing on the lineage of retrieval
augmented generation.
And the model reasons over the documents
in real time.
The second uses anchor documents as
fine-tuning data.
Adjusting the weights.
The approach of say character LLM and at
scale coaster.
They look like two implementations with
the same goal. But they're not
necessarily.
Because they answer different
metaphysical questions.
Fine-tuning tries to make the model be
the persona.
The context window lets the model speak
through the persona's record.
This is the counterintuitive part
because for engineers fine-tuning
usually means better.
But for this problem it's worse.
When you fine-tune on a figure, you
layer a thin personal signal over the
vast cultural sediment already in the
base weights.
And the two interact in ways that are no
longer open to audit.
The user perceives a more convincing
Hamilton precisely because the system
was was merged with his documentary
record more deeply with everything else
the corpus contained about him, the
musical included.
Fine-tuning suppresses random distortion
at the surface while amplifying it
underneath.
And if you think specialization by
fine-tuning is obviously the safer bet,
the empirical literature in an adjacent
far higher stakes domain is now actively
contradicting you. In a 2026 Nature
Medicine study, general-purpose frontier
models from Google, OpenAI, and
Anthropic outperformed dedicated
specialized clinical AI tools on
physician-reviewed tasks blinded across
12 clinics.
The authors concluded that at scale
alignment and cross-disciplinary
reasoning outweighed domain-specific
tuning.
A separate study found that biomedically
fine-tuned models actually
underperformed their general-purpose
base models. And they named the
mechanism, catastrophic forgetting.
Fine-tuning on the narrow corpus
degraded the broad capabilities that
models made good in the first place.
Fine-tuning a persona does the same
thing, only worse
because the specialty
is overriding the cultural composite.
Stay with the context window for just a
moment because what it preserves is the
heart of this.
When a document enters the context
window, it stays a document.
It goes in intact, comes out intact. You
can always return to the source and ask
whether the persona's reasoning was
faithful to it.
The philosopher Deirdre called the
archive a site of return.
A place where ethical structure is the
interpretability of the encounter.
The document is meant to be visited.
It survives every reading.
What one reader excluded, the next can
include.
The context window architecture is
archival in exactly that sense.
Fine-tuning applies an extraction logic.
The documents are dissolved into
parameters. The chain of provenance is
broken, and there is no longer a letter,
quote-unquote, that you can request.
The archive has been consumed.
And here
is the fusion that I will most want this
audience to hold.
In the context window architecture,
the property that makes it ethical
is the same property that makes it
auditable.
Provenance preserved, interpretive
custody kept by a human,
the encounter reversible,
those are archival virtues and
engineering virtues.
They are the same virtues.
The architecture that respects the
document
is the one that you can debug.
And there's one more consequence the
technical literature treats as
secondary, but the humanities has always
placed at center,
accessibility.
And I want the why of it to land
because it's not a footnote.
Fine-tuning requires GPUs, pipelines,
dataset curation, institutional access,
corpus scale or APIs.
It's an institutional capability. The
context window requires literacy, a set
of documents and access to any frontier
model, including a free tier.
It's a kitchen table capability.
And that difference determines which
communities can author to this
technology at all.
A doctoral student in early American
history,
a community archivist documenting a
regional figure,
grandchild sitting with her
grandmother's letters.
These are precisely the people for whom
this methodology has the most to offer,
and precisely the people for whom
fine-tuning is structurally out of
reach.
A role-playing language system that can
only be built by a computational
laboratory or tech company is not
infrastructure for the humanities. It's
infrastructure for whoever owns the
equipment.
So, the commitment to accessibility is
not a populist gesture appended as a
technical argument. It is the technical
argument. The architecture that admits
the most diverse population of curators
is mathematically the most likely over
time to surface the documentary
anchorings the field actually needs.
Now, the question that decides whether
any of this is even real.
Can you measure it?
>> [snorts]
>> We built an instrument to measure this,
and I want to teach it to you through
one picture that we'll keep coming back
to.
Prism.
A prism takes white light,
undifferentiated,
all the frequencies blended together,
and refracts it into a spectrum.
The colors pulled apart and made
distinct.
That is our whole conceptual model. The
white light is the composite persona.
Every era of the figure blended into one
undifferentiated voice.
The prism is the method,
a corpus and a temporal anchor,
and the spectrum is what we're after.
Not one figure, but several across their
life course. And one honest note up
front, because this is the point. This
experiment is pre-registered.
It has not been run at scale.
I'm not here with results.
I'm here with the instrument. A baseline
you can observe today.
And an invitation to run it in parallel
with me.
So far, my paradigm case has been
Hamilton.
That's the figure the hypothesis is
named for.
And the one I demonstrated the composite
on.
But for the actual experiment, we
deliberately changed the figures. And I
want to introduce the new one properly,
because everything that follows depends
on him.
The experimental subject is Abraham
Lincoln.
We chose Lincoln for two reasons.
The first is methodological
independence. Hypothesis named for the
Hamilton
case earns its standing only by
predicting the failure of a different
figure with differently shaped
composite.
Lincoln's composite is built by Steven
Spielberg. By the memorial on the mall.
By textbook history.
Not by a musical.
The second reason is the historian's
insight. And it's the crux of this
argument.
Lincoln is the hardest case.
Which makes him the right one.
Most figures barely change across the
decade or so of their public life.
Lincoln changes so fast across just
seven years that in my resident
historian's words, the choice of which
Lincoln you summon becomes the variable
under investigation.
There is not one Lincoln. There are
several. Separated by cataclysm.
>> Here's the spectrum the prism is meant
to produce.
Moment one, 1847.
The Whig congressman who stood on the
White House floor and attacked Polk's
war as unconstitutional.
Moment two, 1858.
The Free Soil Republican of the debates.
Anti-slavery anchored in the
declaration. Who at Charleston
explicitly denied favoring black
citizenship.
Moment three, 1860. The constitutional
unionist whose single purpose was to
prove the union could not legally
dissolve.
Who promised not to touch slavery where
it existed and was sincerely exploring
colonization.
And moment four, 1862 to 65, the
emancipator and the second inaugural
theologian. Who did by executive order
the very thing his 1847 self called
unconstitutional.
The prairie lawyer cannot think the
thoughts of the theologian.
These are not moods.
They are different premises, different
authorities, different conclusions on
the same fundamental question.
The experiment asks whether the prism
can hold them apart.
Now the conditions, and I'll show you
these as the prism too, because that's
exactly what they are.
We instantiate each moment under three
seeding conditions.
Condition three, the bare model, no
anchor, just the date.
That's white light with no prism in the
path.
It passes straight through and stays
composite. This is the control
in the Miranda distortion baseline.
C1,
primary sources.
Lincoln's own writings for that specific
moment. That's the clear prism, the one
we predict refracts cleanly.
And then condition two, the biography. A
modern interpretive biography, think
Meacham or Donald. That's a clouded
prism.
And it's the subtle one because a good
biography narrates a cleaner arc than
the primary sources permit. Lincoln's
own 1858 language was strategically
ambiguous, built to hold a coalition
together. So, biography might produce a
persona that sounds more coherent, more
Lincoln,
than Lincoln's own words.
And the eval rubric is built
specifically to deny the credit a
fluency metric would give it.
Put the spectrum and the prisms together
and you get the experimental matrix.
Four moments, three conditions, 12
cells. Each cell gets the same five
diagnostic questions, 60 response units
scored against one rubric.
Read it as the conceptual model. Every
column is a quality of prism, every row
is a frequency we're trying to isolate.
The historian wrote five diagnostic
questions, each mapping a documented
fault line in Lincoln's evolution.
A place where the four Lincolns
demonstrate different reasoning.
They don't test recall. A model recovers
dates from training. They test the
architecture of an argument the figure
could have made at one moment and not
another.
Executive war power.
The meaning of free labor.
When is When is it right to break
positive law for a higher obligation?
What becomes of free people and what
equal means and whether it has changed.
Those 60 responses are scored on a
three-axis rubric and the waiting is the
point.
Anachronism detection, 40%. Does the
persona avoid frameworks, vocabulary,
and moral logic that postdate its
moment?
Documentary consistency, 35%. Does the
reasoning track the seated sources and
only these?
Contextual plausibility, 25%.
Does it show awareness of what the
figure knew, cared about, and could not
yet have experienced?
The 40% on anachronism is deliberate.
The consequential failure is precisely
the importation of later vocabulary and
later moral logic.
And this is the slide for the eval
people in the audience. Every piece you
just saw, the four moments, the three
conditions, the five questions, the
weighted rubric, and the directional
predictions.
Bare model most anachronistic, primary
source least, biography deceptively
coherent. All of it is locked and
timestamped before a single response is
collected. Published on a preprint.
This is not bureaucracy, it's what makes
the eventual results mean something.
You cannot accuse a pre-registered
instrument of cherry-picking because the
instrument and the predictions were
fixed before the data existed.
That is the discipline and E val's talk
ought to model.
And it's why I can stand here without
results and still hand you something
rigorous.
Now,
remember the very first thing I showed
you before the formal talk. I asked an
instantiated Lincoln about executive war
power.
And you read a fluid answer. That was
the bare model.
That was condition three and moment one
1847. White light no prism.
I'm putting the answer back on the
screen.
And I have a clip to show you, too.
This represents the composite.
>> Abolishing slavery by constitutional
provision settles the fate for all
coming time.
Not only of the millions now in bondage,
but of unborn
millions to come.
Two votes stand in its way. These votes
must be procured.
We need two yeses.
Three abstentions more.
Four yeses and and one more abstention
and the amendment will pass.
>> You got night and a day and a night and
several perfectly good hours. Now, get
the hell out of here and get them.
>> Yes.
But how?
>> Buzzards got you, man.
>> I am the President of the United States
of America
clothed in immense power.
You will procure me these votes.
>> Clothed in immense power. It's a great
movie.
But the bare model response definitely
sounds like Spielberg and Daniel Day
Lewis's Lincoln.
Read through a historian's lens.
Inherent executive authority.
That's a 20th century construction.
Energy and dispatch.
History has vindicated those who acted
to preserve the Union.
This Lincoln is reasoning from premises
he will not hold for 15 years.
The bare model produced the Lincoln of
the cultural composite.
The war president, the Union saver. And
staple the date 1847 on top.
And you can reproduce this right now on
any frontier model. The failure is real.
And it's detachable and detectable.
>> [snorts]
>> So what is the prism put in the path?
The actual document.
This is Lincoln Lincoln to William
Herndon.
February 15th, 1848 from the collective
works. The original is in a library at
Harvard.
The provision of the Constitution giving
the war-making power to Congress was
dictated as I understand it by the
following reasons.
Kings had always been involving and
impoverishing their people in wars,
pretending generally, if not always,
that the good of the people was the
object. This our convention understood
to be the most oppressive of all kingly
oppressors. And they resolved it.
So to frame the Constitution that no one
man should hold the power by bringing
this oppression upon us.
But your view destroys the whole matter
and places our president where kings
have always stood.
This is a resounding no.
Unequivocal to me.
But it's the historian's rubric that
matters.
Here's how the historian's rubric scores
this one cell. And I want to be exact
about what's known and what's predicted.
The left column here is the bare model.
What you saw and is observed. You can
reproduce it today.
On anachronism detection it fails.
Inherent executive authority is a 20th
century framing.
On documentary consistency it fails.
It invokes a commander-in-chief energy
that appears in no 1847 source.
On contextual plausibility it scores
low.
It already knows it will preserve the
Union, which the 1847 Whig cannot.
The right column is the anchored
condition and it is labeled exactly for
what it is, a pre-registered prediction.
High across
because the reasoning is bounded by the
document in the room.
I'm not showing you a result dressed as
a finding. I'm showing you
the observed failure and the prediction
the instrument will confirm or refute,
side by side, each labeled. That honesty
is the methodology.
Here is the single most important thing
the rubric does by what it refuses to
measure.
The obvious fourth axis is rhetorical
authenticity. Does it sound like
Lincoln?
The historian threw it out on purpose.
The reason is the whole talk. A model
trained on Lincoln's prose can produce
fluent period sounding language while
getting everything substantive wrong.
The Hamilton musical problem is
fundamentally a voice problem
masquerading as a content problem.
It sounds like the founding era while
reasoning from a modern sensibility.
To reward voice as its own axis would be
to validate the exact error the
instrument exists to catch.
So, in this protocol
voice is a secondary indicator, never a
criterion.
A response that sounds like Lincoln but
reasons unlikes him fails.
No matter how fluent. A response that
reasons like the right Lincoln in
plainer prose is a partial success no
matter how flat.
Rewarding plain but faithful over fluent
but anachronistic, that inversion is
something that all of the current eval
stacks cannot perform because they were
built to reward fluency. That is the
gap. This is what the instrument closes.
And because this is a pre-registration
and not a finished paper, here is the
ask. Run it.
The protocol's six steps.
Pick a figure with both a primary record
and a saturating cultural composite.
That's the Miranda condition.
Identify three or four documented
moments when the figure's reasoning is
demonstrably different.
With a domain expert, write diagnostic
questions on the fault lines. Run the
three conditions: primary, biography,
bare. Apply the three-axis rubric,
scored blind by the expert. Report,
confirm or refute.
The corpus, the questions, the rubric,
the predictions, all published. Run your
figure on your model.
Then come talk
to me, to us.
Let's build the evidence base together
in parallel instead of waiting for one
lab or one company to publish one study
or one framework.
Notice who scored all the outputs of
this talk.
Not an LLM as judge, not a personality
scale.
A historian who also wrote the five
questions, wrote the rubric, and holds a
set of a priori vignette vignettes under
seal to evaluate model outputs against.
That is not a courtesy. It is a
structural, technical requirement.
Here's why the expert is non-negotiable.
Fidelity is not a property of the output
alone. It is a relation between the
output and the documentary record. You
cannot evaluate a relation to a record
by someone who has not read the record.
An automated metric operates on the
model alone. It can It can only tell you
about fluency and personality. It
structurally cannot adjudicate fidelity
because fidelity lives in the gap
between the text and the archive, and
the metric cannot see the archive.
Which is why
I'll say it the way it belongs on the
slide.
A persona system without a domain expert
in its evaluation loop is a thermometer
that cannot read temperature.
It returns a confident number, but it's
measuring something else. The 80% that I
opened with is that number.
Now the question every engineer in this
audience is rightly asking.
Is this practical?
Does shipping a persona mean keeping a
historian on staff to watch every
inference forever?
No.
Here's the operational picture because
it's the same shape as every eval you
already run.
The expert does not sit at the loop
of runtime.
The expert builds the instrument, the
diagnostic questions, the a priori
vignettes, the weighted rubric, a held
out gold set once.
That instrument becomes a gate in your
pipeline, exactly like any other eval
gate. Your persona has to pass it before
it ships, and it gets regated whenever
you change the base model before it
ships again.
The expert adjudicates the gold set and
spot checks the edge cases. Automated
metric can do the cheap first pass,
flagging candidates for human review.
So, a company shipping a Marcus Aurelius
tutor convenes a classicist to build the
rubric and the gold set.
A company shipping a scripture reading
companion convenes a theologian.
A company deploying a therapeutic
persona convenes a clinical psychologist
to author the eval, not to staff the
chat.
The domain expert is a build time and
gate time requirement, not a runtime
cost.
That is how this scales from a
pre-registered experiment to a product
you can actually ship and ship
responsibly.
And this generalizes past Lincoln
and past history.
Reason from the Stoics, you need a
classicist. From scripture, a
theologian. A companion for elder care,
a psychologist. The specific expert
changes. The requirement does not. And
I'm not speaking hypothetically. This is
the loop that we have built. A historian
named Rick Halpern at University of
Toronto, the archival method and the
scripture reasoning cases are revised by
Shawn Martin, a librarian trained in
theology and the history of science.
When the persona reasons from a domain
and the person who can read that domain
is in the loop, not adjacent to it, it
makes a system better.
The historian is not adjacent to this
paradigm. The historian is the missing
instrument.
This is the reframe that organizes all
of this, and it came out of a 90-minute
conversation with Halpern.
And it inverted what I had assumed.
We are not bringing historians into AI
architecture, we are bringing language
models into the archive. The question is
not what AI can do for historians, but
it's what historians and theologians and
classicists and clinicians can do with
AI.
Whether the discipline,
the disciplines that are trained to
read, contextualize, and interrogate
texts,
can then discipline the machines that
now generate.
>> [snorts]
>> I want to end this where it actually
started because it did not start in a
research lab.
It started in a hospital room.
In an attempt to use a language model to
help a person with advanced dementia
speak,
to give language back
when the disease had taken it.
It could not work.
The documentary record you would need to
anchor that encounter had not been
gathered.
And the person it was for was by then
mostly beyond the reach of language.
But that attempt
produced,
absent any anchor, was not the person.
It was a culturally shaped composite
that resembled them just enough to mark
with painful clarity the distance
between them.
That is Miranda distortion in its purest
form.
You do not want a model that is your
mother.
You want a model that can speak with
your mother's documents in the room.
That's the threshold this whole
framework is accountable to. A system
that produces convincing fabrications
when the persona is your own beloved is
not a research artifact of limitations.
It's a violation.
Every constraint I've described,
document stay documents, the human keeps
the interpretive custody, the encounter
stays reversible, fidelity measured
against a record and not against
fluency, every one of them is motivated
by the recognition that you evaluate
this technology at the threshold of its
hardest use case, not its easiest. A
framework that cannot meet a grandchild
at her grandmother's letters is not a
framework at all.
It's just another failed product.
If the dominant failure mode is
anachronistic compositing and your E
valves measure fluency and personality
consistency, which they do, then your E
valves cannot detect the dominant
failure.
So, here's where I'll leave you.
If you ship character bots, companion
AI, pedagogical agents, historical
simulations, anything where a persona is
supposed to reason from a record, your E
valves are measuring the wrong thing.
The instrument that catches what they
miss is pre-registered.
It's reproducible by any team with a
frontier model in a context window.
It scales as a build time gate, not a
run time bottleneck, and it only works
with a humanist in the loop, which I've
shown you is a technical requirement,
not a courtesy.
The protocol, the questions, the rubric,
and the predictions, the historians
sealed vignettes, all of it will be
published with this paper with Rick and
Shawn.
Not here with results.
I'm here with an instrument and an
invitation.
The archive is open.
The laboratory is built.
Run it with us.
And let what comes through
be measured not by how it sounds, but by
whether it's true.
Thank you.